google ist eine plattform die wir alle
nahezu täglich nutzen um dinge zu
googeln doch wie oft werden diese dinge
eigentlich gegoogelt darauf meine damen
und herren geht es in den heutigen video
und zwar spielen wir mal wieder das
hanauer game lebens wo jetzt ein logo
eingeblendet luca bei dem heiler game
geht es darum dass wir hier auf der
einen seite etwas angegeben haben wie
beispielsweise den wrestler triple age
der wird nämlich monatliche 368.000
googelt und dann müssen wir hier sagen
ob der fc barcelona mehr gegoogelt wird
eher weniger
es ist der verdammte fc barcelona also
natürlich mehr das heißt wir klicken
jetzt einfach drauf sehen der fc
barcelona wird an die zehn millionen mal
gegoogelt
nun haben wir eine neue sache und zwar
50 shades of traders wird nicht so
häufig gegoogelt würde ich sagen nämlich
noch anderthalb millionen mal daniel
roos würde ich sagen mehr als weniger
jetzt haben wir verloren
dezember sings nicht
wir kommen haltet doch einfach eure
fresse larry bird keine ahnung wer das
sein soll oder brian clough weiß ich
auch nicht das ist aber ich glaube da
wird noch weniger häufig googelt nämlich
nur ein zehntel von larry bird sachen
dobermann ist eine hunderasse die wird
er auf jeden fall mehr google als 33.000
mal die undertaker basierende wrestling
edition aus
ich habe gerade voll gespuckt und jetzt
ist nur ein kompletter monitors
die undertaker safe mehr als 200.000 mal
nämlich das doppelte
dann haben wir william shakespeare auch
häufiger nämlich 550.000 mal das nächste
ist black safe 2,2 millionen black
mirror mit einer von den besten serien n
dies gibt nach konkreter weil der stadt
auch in serie und fügt ago rasse alter
das hat mich an meine schulzeit
definitiv weniger als black mirror
nämlich nur 200.000 mal los angeles
lakers safe häufiger nämlich dachte was
geht in die millionen mit denen das halt
krass wenn man überlegt dass der fc
barcelona an die zehn millionen mal
gegoogelt wird und die lakers somit
eines der besten basketball teams der
welt nur 450.000 mal das ist schon echt
wenig worte schienen alter kommen geht
ich vergraben 5000 mal ist der geringste
score den ich je gesehen habe
thesaurus
was ist thesaurus ein thesaurus einer
sprache ordnete deren wörter nach themen
und wort feldern die ihn vor allem zum
auffinden besser passender wörter beim
schreiben und erhält dafür wieso wird
das siebeneinhalb millionen mal
gegoogelt vandalismus hey weniger alter
siebeneinhalb millionen das ist schon
krass krass fiel burberry auf jeden fall
mehr nämlich 18 millionen mal
dann haben wir die nächste sache allen
iverson ich keine ahnung wer das ist ich
glaube mal ein basketballer würde ich
jetzt einmal so grob sagen weniger als
auch richtig sogar nur einen fünften mal
usain bolt auf jeden fall mehr das geht
auch in die millionen 1,2 millionen
procter gamble ich glaub weniger jetzt
wo ich dachte schon bieling
keine ahnung ich würde sagen nein 14
so dass das war übel gut vietnam wird
häufiger als 50.000 mal gegoogelt
nämlich 1,2 millionen mal basketball
auch häufiger an nämlich das doppelte
2,2 millionen mal hey wie auch
heuschnupfen
das könnte eng werden ich würde sagen
weniger es sogar gar nicht eng aber
haben ja selbst ein viele leute george
orwell würde ich sagen häufiger nämlich
250.000 mal die nächste sache qi
m
kein plan ich würde sagen hey es ist
aber genau gleich viel
ist halt genau gleich viel dafür stehe
ich mit meinem namen die zehn gebote für
bohr freunde ich würde sagen mehr
nämlich 368.000 mal aber auch nicht so
viel mehr yoga geht auch in die
millionen nämlich an die zwei millionen
hillary clinton auf jeden fall noch was
wir haben den quality score cosmetic
surgery oder coffee shop ich würde sagen
coffeeshop öfter nämlich 673.000 mal
alles recycelt wird weniger häufig
gegoogelt ist ja nur ein ganz normaler
kinofilm awards neuer auch weniger ich
glaube so viele leute lassen sich jetzt
nicht scheiden ende juli also diese
hiphop rap crew würde ich sagen safe
mehr als 10.000 mal ich jetzt sogar
gesagt das geht in die millionen
irgendwie birds auf jeden fall häufiger
dass es fast schon zehn millionen
samsung ist jetzt wieder ein bisschen
schwieriger ich würde sagen wien ein
alter elf millionen mal
wenn ich solche zahlen sehe elf
millionen dann frage ich mich immer wie
oft ich gegoogelt werde
das gehört das so gemacht als er tot ist
wiegt also summa summarum look zeigen
ich würde sagen meine damen und herren
machen noch eine letzte runde und 2 xbox
one hat fünf millionen die terminator
hat definitiv weniger nämlich nur 74
1200 natürlich schon gut vorgelegt karl
renzl auf jeden fall häufiger geht auch
in die millionen 2,2 millionen kraft ist
das was ich ganz viel habe kraft wird
weniger häufig gegoogelt nämlich 165.000
mal hafen post ist häufiger 7,5
millionen ist ja eine der größten
zeitung in england jupiter weniger
nämlich eine million dass er jupiter da
kannst du dich echt schämen gehen law
school würde ich sagen auch weniger
nämlich nur 41.000 dann haben wir als
nächstes
nicht nur dass emma ist sixx das gebäude
hier steht auf jeden fall in london
direkt an der themse das weiß ich würd
mal sagen häufiger nämlich 201
tausendmal hillsborough disaster weniger
als jetzt auch schon ein paar jährchen
her wollen ich hoffe ihr wisst dass das
wohin ich respektlos rüber kommen sollte
mit dem von wegen das ist ja auch schon
ein paar jährchen her also das ist
natürlich gerade was damals passiert ist
im hillsborough stadion also das sind ja
hunderte haben sich verletzt und sind
gestorben in dem stadion damals bei der
katastrophe also freuen das sollte nicht
respektlos rüberkommen aber jetzt weiter
mit dem heiler geben thomas edison wird
denke ich häufiger gegoogelt nämlich an
die halbe millionen mal pro monat israel
auf jeden fall mehr das geht an die zwei
millionen hier sogar das nächste lsd
auch häufiger weniger 10
ich muss allerdings sagen wir waren
diesmal krass krass gut
an der stelle wird das video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gerne mal einen like da will ich mich
sehr darüber freuen falls sie noch kein
abonnent auf einem kanal seit ich habe
ein super film hier für euch aber nie
zeit dafür und es will
lassen abo danke danke da kann man mich
ja nur noch abonnieren
und jetzt will ich an der stelle einfach
nur noch sagen okay